happy hump day reject nation john
humphreys favorite day of the week
all the time always so we're gonna watch
today
a video that was sent over to me by a
handful
of folks from the hit channel the
hilarious channel
rdc world one there's a link in the
description box and pinned comment
if you guys want to go check out more of
their videos check out the original link
to this video
subscribe to them i'm just looking
forward to this because the title how
marvel heroes feel
about the new eternals movie let's let's
see what's going on
let's see what's going
thor on of thunder man how are you i'm
doing good
just doing what gods do i am a god
uh come again what happened you're fat
now
no i'm not fat i just got a little bit
bigger i've been working out a little
bit
asgard eating good you know
panka how are you it's groaning now
ronin yes that's what i said and who
gave you that
give it to me myself actually isn't
there another one in the guardians of
the galaxy
who the [ __ ] is that
anyway have you seen the new returners
trailer
yeah i've seen it what'd you think about
it doesn't matter
i had to handle myself when everybody
disappeared i'll do it then i'll do it
now
you have a what handle everything yeah
everything you mean that common game in
japan
i'm a whole different person because of
that you don't know what i went through
nobody here knows what i went through i
think literally half the planet knows
mr blade first black superhero right
blake you knew that
have you seen the returners trailer no
no no why not it's a talk of the town
no blade is the talk of the town well
here's not the talk of the town
yes it is what town
every town especially at night because
guess what when the vampires come out
who they need
blade i bet you they talking about blade
so you heard the new eternal trailer
though yeah yeah i'm real happy for him
real happy glad it's out all right
yeah you're not mad or anything no
no why would i be mad
i mean yeah see i i am the hulk i am
supposed to be mad but i just feel like
it doesn't get me anywhere you know
it literally helps people you see that
that's how that's how this happened i
you know i just feel like it's just not
gonna work anymore just
getting mad i should have my mind
straight at all times now you know
yeah i've seen it that's supposed to be
our protectors or whatever
yeah they were supposed to protect us
well that
you probably thought you could handle it
where are men tell that's iron man how
are you doing
hey interviewer
i can't call it i can't call it you have
to hear that
have you seen an eternal trailer uh yeah
i've seen it i've seen it it was
it was good it was good
ready to see why you know they weren't
there when you know when we was fighting
thanos but
i'm ready to see it when we were
fighting thanos
yeah we me cap
uh iron man rest assault
all of us a lot of us out there
aren't you supposed to be able to heal
why is your arm in a swing
no no see see i'm not getting mad
anymore that's just
that's not the way to go i just want to
be you know
myself smart that's a smart thing to do
i mean you let your anger take control
then it's just gonna what
i'm the first i'm the first hero
everybody knew marvel to have no black
fan bases before me
so marvel had no black fans before not
one not one
not one fan name them
david i'm pretty sure they have because
there was nothing
until blade popped up on the screen and
the only reason why they didn't put me
to mcu because they know i would beat
thanos quick
quick you can't be captain america but i
fight vampires that stronger than thanos
and captain america set it up then
okay first of all set it up set it up i
ain't gonna talk too much set it up
captain america is dead you can't fight
him he's dead
yeah have you seen the eternal trailer
though
yeah i seen it was it was nice it was
good i guess i don't know
not thinking too much about it you know
they say
they're stronger than the avengers right
i've never heard that
yeah well i mean they might be stronger
than them but i mean
me no i i'm a god i mean i don't know if
they know that the tunnels
i've heard they might be uh what are
they eternal or something i'm a god
yeah i feel like they can definitely
battle with you and maybe
they might be able to get you now that
you're like out of shape
who the [ __ ] is out of shape because i
keep saying that he's out of shape
me no
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know you know how to stay you know
hey falcon how are you doing oh it's
captain america
hey falcon how are you doing i'm good
man what's up
i'm good as well did you see the new
eternal struggle yeah i saw it was i
well you do know that they were just
watching as you guys were fighting for
the lives
most of you actually lost their lives
yeah i know
you don't feel any weight oh yeah i do
they scare you
yes if they weren't they would have been
out there fighting like me and everybody
else
you were fighting yes i was fighting
can you name one of your highlights one
of my highlights
yeah i mean and winter soldier i helped
captain america fight bucky
you know what i'm saying i mean i would
tell you my show but i mean
that's like 10 years ago what
do you do you feel like the eternal [ __ ]
helped y'all fight bucky
we didn't need it we had that taken care
of
how was it was it had that taken care of
yeah cat
no captain america african american
that's what this is yeah yeah
yes i was i was in the movie i was
telling you i was in the back
and i was just showing you the guns i
came with actually i don't think you're
in the
entire mcu
i mean i just feel like you disrespect
me every time i get on the interview
[Music]
i i am an mcu i have a movie i was an
in-game
uh right after right after cap said what
he said what
did kept saying he said oh avengers
assembled
you were there yes he said avengers
assemble
show me i went from a bow to a sword
overnight why would you do that
what i'm not too familiar with bro i'm
pretty sure
not when i'm on the roster it's not when
i'm on the roster
not my scene not from that teaser does
black widow not mean anything
yeah she means everything to me i mean
things happen
i mean you know things happen
yeah things happen she lived a great
life she died because of like
your mission with thanos you know the
same person whooped your ass
yeah but he beat you up
[Music]
i understand but they have their points
i have mine
no that's not the way to go that's what
i'm saying sat there and watched black
widow die
i understand but that's just that's
their points
you know they have their points i have
mine
yes i am come on i'm still strong what
are you talking about
there it is no no no see
i'm still i'm still level-minded
set it up i don't want that i can't set
it up
and i bet you come out with another
metal arm i'm willing to bet that if you
guys fight
he will take no damage at all
you gonna lose your money but captain
america did more with your hammer than
you did against thanos come again
captain america used your hammer better
than you thor
you use my hammer better than me but i
mean i'm not worthy
this dudes are hilarious man so funny
punisher one
easily my favorite yeah absolutely
because i i love how
each one of these personalities hones in
on a certain
thing about each one of their egos
even down to the hulk who's like so
ambivalent to getting angry and like
completely apprehensive towards i don't
want to fight i i don't want to
i don't want any conflict i don't want
to deal with any of that
brute anymore yeah but even there you
know you're still poking at his like
defense mechanisms and his ego so i
thought that was just such a funny
approach you do that with all them like
like with thor who's out of shape
who's out of shape i love that but
especially the punisher bit like he's
got the
the the cadence the little the quick
delivery on it because i like the bro
attitude that they bring to all
of the all the characters like they're
pretty much putting themselves in their
own
their personalities into these marvel
characters with punishers specifically i
like that whole bit about trying to
convince him of the importance of his
his uh his role in the mcu and his role
in the fight
and how he was there the whole time is
that was absolutely hysterical blade has
got to probably be the best
yeah yeah and then for me probably
number three would be doctor strange
even though he was used sparingly like
especially when he showed up i was like
of all the
avengers you would probably have the
most sort of ego beef with the eternals
for being out there and not stepping in
because you already have so much of a
hand in the cosmic side of the universe
his character portrayal seemed to be
because they all had like i said an ego
but his character portrayal specifically
was one of like but i don't need to be
here i'm better yeah yeah
yeah i guess this is the only attitude
where
you believe he would win yeah he would
probably do better than all of them
yeah whereas everyone else is kind of
trying to save face yeah
yeah and hype up their role in this
person
like dr strange has no interest in doing
that because he doesn't need to
yeah or like with falcon too
just trying to take credit for it like i
was saying yeah
i'm captain you know i'm steve what are
you talking about man
this is captain america it's so freaking
funny it's hilarious yeah i get why this
was sent out away by a bunch of people
and i love these kind of youtube videos
these kind of youtube sketches are kind
of my favorite because they're they're
so simple
yeah like is it the best sound in the
world no it's not the best sound in the
world is it going all out on production
design
uh no but it still takes time it still
takes creativity it still takes fun
improvisation
still takes editing and uh part of the
the lo-fi
quality to the execution of it is a big
part of its charm
so yeah you know it's like a lot of
times with sketch like to me
this is part of the inspirational side
of youtube to me because of the fact
that they're
they do stuff that's simple enough to
put together like you got to get the
props
and everything costume yeah you got to
find the bits of how to approach the
characters for it
but at the same time you know it is just
uh it's homespun like yeah you do this
on your own yeah it's like it's classic
youtube in a way
yeah i love how these guys like keep
that vibe at energy alive you know
absolutely because sometimes that's all
you need to make some really really
funny comments
anyway guys like i mentioned at the top
of this video link in the description
box for rdc world
one you go show them some love if you
haven't subscribed to this make a
channel
already subscribe to us click the
notification bell thank you to everyone
who recommended this our way
hit that like button last but not least
let's do up
everett baker i don't think we've
shouted you out yet everett so thank you
for joining our patreon page
uh also did want to give you a
traditional type of shadow
e stands for eternal
you will eternally be a part of our
patreon page
as long as you're pledged v stands for
um
valentine cause i wish you would be my
valentine next year everett
e again stands for
economical because you really know how
to handle your finances or where to put
your money towards patreon pages
r stands for regal
because you are an elegant kingly fellow
e it stands for
uh extraordinary because
let's face it three e's in one name that
must mean something extraordinary
and a t stands for tenacious
because you have such a drug you never
give up everett that's why you got so
many e's in your name
and another t stands for
scaring because you and steve rogers
nope not rogers
would be the only men allowed on
that piece of honey land honey land
express
right never ever wait i hope you
identify as
and well if you don't you know i
i'm going to assume you're a guy